this video is going to have Game of
Thrones spoilers up until season 8
episode 3 Game of Thrones has it's fair
to say captured a lot of attention and
while it is of course about the
characters and their loves and trials
and concerns and unpleasant fates it's
ultimately about people fighting for
power in the shadow of a looming
external threat that cannot be bargained
with and indeed can only be escaped
through the expenditure of tremendous
resources basically if there's any
real-world analog to Game of Thrones
it's the geopolitics of global warming
this isn't even really conjecture george
RR martin has said as much in a very
broad sense there's a certain parallel
there where we're fighting our own
battles we're fighting over issues
important issues my new foreign policy
domestic policy but none of them are
important if like we're dead and our
cities are under the ocean when the Song
of Ice and Fire begins Westeros is live
and large a ten-year summer the longest
in living history has brought the nation
so much prosperity that there's plenty
of resources left over to invest in
armies and backstabbing and war and so
there are armies and backstabbing and
war the focus is on who can win power
because there's nothing else to worry
about
but even without the threat of inhuman
cold men no one will let you forget
remember winters in Westeros are a thing
outside of White Walkers they come at
random they last sometimes for a year
sometimes for many years and if you're
not prepared people die preparing for
winter is a thing in Westeros it's a
collective action that people take to
avoid famine and death and if you go to
war right before a winter feed all of
your grain stores to the golden company
and torch the crops of your enemy's
winter for the continent is not going to
go well and we start out Game of Thrones
with academic experts assuring people
that this winter is going to be a bad
one
stocks are all's right eventually the
strong will be long and we continue with
no one heeding those warnings because
short term geopolitics feels much more
important after 10 years of summer but
then of course it turns out more than
just winter is coming that's when we
move right into the stages
of threat denial number one no one
believes it the fishermen of Lannisport
say they see mehmed's
number two people who have any right at
all to know all agree but they are
completely incapable of convincing those
who benefit from the status quo or who
will be asked to sacrifice a
substantially how do I convince people
you don't know me that an enemy they
don't believe in is coming to kill them
all three the people who actually have
good information go above and beyond to
convince everyone for the people who
benefit from the status quo finally
accept that the threat is real but are
unwilling to make the necessary
sacrifices because ultimately that would
weaken them you pledged our forces to
find our common essence a whatever I
need to say to ensure the survival of
our house it's a kind of prisoner's
dilemma no matter what the best thing
for any individual is to not expend
resources facing the challenge if other
people do and the problem gets handled
you're all good and you got there for
free if the challenge is not overcome
you are still better off than the people
who spent all those resources but of
course the analog is not perfect and I
want to discuss three reasons why
because I think that it sheds some light
on the magnitude of the difficulty of
the problem of climate change number one
you can't beat global warming
Fox also did a video on Game of Thrones
and climate change and they had this to
say stopping it requires the world's
biggest nations like China India and the
u.s. to sacrifice a little in the short
term and put away their political
competition with each other
unfortunately this is a little bit
ludicrous the reality is that we don't
have to sacrifice a little we have to
sacrifice a lot we like flying to visit
our parents we like living in 2,000
square foot homes we like it when gas
isn't $5 a gallon and we like eating
hamburgers and many people who don't
currently get to do those things would
be rightly frustrated if suddenly we
decided that no new people were allowed
access to that lifestyle and so in this
way our problem is worse than the night
king as much as people would like to
pretend that this isn't the case there
is a cost to leaving fossil fuels in the
ground it is not as great as the fossil
fuel companies and the politicians who
are paid by them would have you believe
but it exists we don't get to throw a
Dothraki horde of the problem there's no
boss man we can stab and be done with it
John in your last video you talked about
how a goalie in soccer has to scramble
every
time even though 95% of the time it will
make a difference because the 5% matters
but the thing about hope and sports is
that at the end of a soccer game someone
wins and that feels good and so it is
with battles and White Walkers
but with global warming we will spend
resources and we will do it indefinitely
but we will not do it to win we do it to
make life on average a little bit better
and for me
that is the thing with feathers not a
binary switch but a constant push on the
bell curve of suffering because every
millimetre that thing moves is a mother
that doesn't lose her child to
waterborne illness or a family that
doesn't have to flee their home our
night king is maybe unsurprisingly
ourselves and our Battle of Winterfell
is shoving on that bell curve of
suffering every day until we're dead
which brings me to number two we are
fighting ourselves climate change is
literally the first global scale
collective problem our species has ever
faced it's not surprising that we don't
know how to face it we like solving
problems that look familiar problems we
know how to solve tyrion says as much
white walkers the knight king army of
the dead it's almost a relief to
confront a comfortable familiar monster
like my sister like this our changing
climate video on global warming and Game
of Thrones says we concentrate our
efforts on the Cersei Lannister zuv the
world problems that we can understand
and for which there are established
solutions but this is not a familiar
problem it's not a familiar conversation
and even more than any of that climate
change isn't evil it's not immoral we
can say that the problem is big dirty
evil fossil fuel companies but we say it
at conferences that we flew to in planes
and buildings that are cooled by coal
even if we live a pleasant green
lifestyle now even if we do make that
conversion we will only have been able
to do it because of the tremendous
surplus created by the last hundred
years of burning ancient sunlight the
White Walkers are at least evil and ugly
the night King wants to kill us global
warming doesn't want to kill us
it
simply on effect of humans doing their
best to make life better for themselves
and their children
no one really likes to talk about this
because it's not a clean-cut story but
ultimately there is less suffering in
the world because of fossil fuels
attempting to turn them into an amoral
thing while exonerating the humans who
used the resource ultimately can never
ring entirely true and last number three
you can touch a white so White Walkers
want to do us harm while global warming
does not but that's not even the biggest
problem here you can also like see and
touch them and we try to do that here on
earth with graphs and visualizations and
dramatic footage of glaciers but that is
not the same as being nearly eaten by a
zombie if Westeros was a perfect analog
for our world they'd be having three
different arguments right now one about
whether the white was just a dramatic
hoax one about whether there's even
anything we can do about it and a final
one about whether there are enough of
them to even concern ourselves with
because of this difference Season eight
has been able to take this analogy to an
interesting geopolitical place
ultimately seeing the threat some people
who disagreed with each other did come
together and sacrificed tremendous
resources to end the threat despite the
fact that it will significantly decrease
their ability to continue to fight a war
and to feed people as even if the White
Walkers aren't coming the winter still
is but the person in the best situation
is the one who did nothing to combat the
looming exterior threat she let everyone
else spend their resources and kept all
her own and that it turns out was the
right choice and isn't that the most
frustrating thing because while the
psychology of White Walkers and global
warming is different the geopolitics is
basically the same any individual nation
that makes sacrifices hurts only
themselves while helping everyone
equally
while any nation that doesn't gets the
gains with none of the sacrifice and so
even in a world where we understand the
threat and appreciate its magnitude
which were still a long way off from the
game isn't stacked in favor of Sue
Lucian's the best course of action for
any individual is to do nothing while
everyone equally reaps the benefits of
the people who sacrifice this is the
lesson of Game of Thrones and now you're
probably thinking well I suppose it's
hopeless then maybe our heroes figured
something out in Fantasyland and we'll
all have to imagine that they find some
way coming back from their losses but
here on this planet ah we're hosed but
there are also ways in which our problem
is better than the problem that Westeros
has we have a massive malleable planet
that is much less unpredictable than
theirs and it has huge amounts of
resources and we have extremely advanced
technology that is already pushing the
boundaries of what we thought possible
in terms of pace of change we have
brains made for problem solving in the
last five years
16 percent of coal plants in the US have
closed down there may never be another
one built in this country again in 2017
we lost four gigawatts of coal power in
the US and gained seven gigawatts of
wind this shift is gonna take decades
even centuries but it's happening now
and so there's kind of a fourth
difference between our situation and
theirs
this isn't a battle we're not here to
win or lose but we do always change we
move forward and that's something that
it seems like we're actually way better
at than Westeros John I'll see you on
Tuesday